so nice to be back a lot of things have
changed the last time I was on TV I had
to get permission to say the word
[ __ ] yeah now I can just quote The
Wall Street Journal right that is now a
headline in the Wall Street Journal my
favorite too is the people that think
they're getting away we're seeing s hole
which just sounds like [ __ ] yes
there's no good president said s hole
but they'll say s hole in the first part
of the paragraph and then later they'll
say [ __ ] hole yeah it's just completely
defeats the purpose fantastic I can't
wait till the Queen starts it that's
right queen elizabeth's there's like a
sailor Liz Lemon must point out today is
Martin Luther King Day yeah just to
break it down for you young people a
long time ago there used to be something
called racism yeah glad that's behind us
huh
let's just bum this guy out he's like no
it still exists so thank you sir for
putting me back at heat I appreciate it
you're right it still exists thank you
Twitter's in the news Congress is
questioning Twitter about allowing
extremists on their site yeah
in response Twitter said we have to he's
the president this is a good sign you
had a lot of negative news out there
this is good North Korea and South Korea
are considering having a joint women's
ice hockey team for the Olympics
of course when a North Korean player
enters the penalty box they're never
seen again
everything bums him out he's in here and
these are the noises he's making cuz he
got shot yeah I wish you were there to
comment like that throughout my entire
life Saudi Arabia settle down sir he's
preparing his saudi arabia has lifted a
35-year ban on movie theaters and the
first movie to screened publicly was the
emoji movie yeah so the ban is back on
wait so I'm what 1 4 4 with this guy
actually historically pretty good for a
pretty good yeah that's above my average
you